very happy to be here to do another
interview this time with Harlan table a
good friend of mine from Oslo who leads
the it's the Oslo Stoics I think he's a
philosophy student at the University of
Oslo and one of the things that
particularly caught my eye and I thought
might be of interest everybody is the
fact that he has taken on the Herculean
labor of translating Epictetus into
Norwegian so that's quite a commitment
and that's I know from having taken
everything translation things just just
how easy it is to take on something that
seems put workable and you get into it
so you've got several chapters done
already right what what's your
impression on the task so far well I
think it's actually what you well
compared to other projects so for
instance I find that it's much easier
than what might be a challenge is to
capture the tone and it's very directly
with his interlocutors students
sometimes local people you know even
officials yeah especially the chapter on
personal I went to work yeah yeah book 3
yeah yeah was it put through your book
to bring the student comes in dressed up
too much yeah I think it's book 3 okay
it tells them to cut off his genitals
and hang himself well an epic tears -
calls people slave which I guess he's in
many respects allowed to do since he was
a slave himself yeah
and that's something that a long brings
up in his book when talks about freedom
being one of the dominant themes and
epictetus and i guess it makes sense for
educators to call this buildin slaves
because they are slaves to their
passions and things like that so yeah
and here's that that line - if you
desire something that another has
control over you make make yourself a
slave to that person which certainly
seems to be true so how did you get
interested first of all how did you get
interested in stoicism and then what
made you think that it's about time to
translate
Epictetus discourses into not just in
our region but the first scandinavian
translation right yeah this will be as
far as some of the first translations
and his Canadian language of discourses
and well I think the stoicism in general
is having a renaissance now
we love to people who are discussing it
now and it seems to me about time
together in the region translation so
our other Norwegian or other skinny and
Scandinavian language translations of
Marcus Aurelius or Seneca or any of the
other stoic figures I'm not sure whether
they're on this we issued a new some
Danish translations I am pretty sure
that there are there is a Norwegian
translation of Marcus Aurelius okay from
the late fifties I believe oh that's
actually quite good it's a big fashion
but yeah that's that's one of the things
we struggle with you know the public
domain texts in English are always very
old-fashioned language the newer tax
returns of course you have to pay for it
with contemporary language you know and
we almost have too many choices in the
English between different editions they
don't imagine that that's that much of
an issue in the region right no no that
there's only one translation of Marcus
Aurelius there are two translations of
thank Iridium
and one seems to be currently after
print like complicated at least and
that's the modern one others
translation from like 20 or something
like that into not migration but the
automation which is a bit more tricky to
read so it has there been a very big
transformation in the 20th century from
Norwegian as you might find it in the
1920s you know what would have been
spoken around the turn of our century
not too much but there are two official
written standards in the region and oh
one is called malt and another it's
called new nostril generation okay so
the language and you the region
interesting and new nature is based on
the dialects and Western codes so if you
go back about a hundred year that
quickness tanner is going to be a bit
different from what you read today okay
but if you read like let's say hello
Gibson or Thompson yeah
late a market century that's part
readable than good so I imagine that one
of the reasons for translating any start
touched into Norwegian would be that you
know many people in Scandinavia are
English as a Second Language
I imagine that for some it's not well to
varying degrees I mean I think and
interesting philosophy will be able to I
don't speak English are perhaps a few
eight words people
our interesting process of learning
Norwegian as a second language yeah
maybe I haven't so so what is the I know
there's there's definitely some personal
reasons and there's things that you
learn along the way and translating but
then what is the impetus for providing a
Norwegian translation well just to be
able to do it there yeah like like Mount
Everest yeah we couldn't find any so
we're just already a process that's
perfectly fine thanks now hope to be
able to use this for a lobster feast or
something like that
that's a great idea yeah that's a good
project because then you can even
translate it write a commentary yeah so
I think a lot of my viewers will won't
know about this but that's kind of a a
common process both in classics and in
philosophy I supposed to if you're doing
ancient history or literature
instead of writing a dissertation where
you're saying I'm gonna unpack this kind
of the concept of freedom and epictetus
blah blah blah blah blah you actually
translate a previously untranslated text
or provide a new translation and then
the commentary says why one made the
choices as a translator here and there
to the render things this way around
and with that continuous oh that's
that's actually a good lead-in to a
question with Epictetus there's a number
of greek terms that we've talked about
that are somewhat difficult to translate
well into English and I'm wondering if
they're the same issues arise with
respect to Scandinavian languages you
know for like saying poor erases the
pre-greek mouth where the sure if there
is news in the region translation so you
know with you know I I don't know
Scandinavian languages but I know German
and I know that it's very easy to to go
to the roots and you know just cram a
bunch of words together is that and
available little technique you could say
at or rendering things like preferably
like like in a prior ASIS if we think
about it in terms of preference
while Germany can just say for Damon and
it's almost it's really the same time
and it's all thrown together can you do
that in Norwegian though
yeah probably okay yeah actually
probably say something like for
officials or something like that okay
it's a bunch of options now it just
yesterday was a good choice for
translations or is it better to come up
with a new term oh well I think it
sounds to be taught so I'll probably try
to you term yeah but I think I'll have
to rock the list of the Turks to begin
the or glossary yeah awesome
yeah and perhaps even keep the turtles
in Greek yeah yeah there's good a few
technical s some idea if pneumonia for
instance that's a tough one
yeah my standard translation for
happiness in which movie that sort of
just beats happiness it can also be a
verb what it guess which means to
succeed something that was the my
professor is the translation of it so
then you move the focus away from mental
state oh yeah
so that's one thing
yeah I mean we we struggle to translate
it into English but I sometimes think
you know they often because of virtue
ethics it's miss Renaissance want to say
well let's translate unite ammonia's
flourishing and that's such an
old-fashioned word you know maybe
fulfillments is something that works
better yeah so there's a teleology there
getting to what you're supposed to be
the only trouble is we've got so much
new agey self-help stuff that's all
about personal fulfillment as it starts
to sound now is that is that something
that you see in in Norwegian there's
self-help books is big yeah as they are
here yeah problem crime fiction big
books and self-help books that tends to
be the big rips in the book story okay
yeah the philosophy section and well if
you go to a university bookstore of
course it's different but most of
American bookstores they'll be a
philosophy section and only half of the
stuff in there is actually philosophy
this also principle is
though isn't too because it's yeah I
mean it can be taken to be self help in
some ways so you you lead is a small but
growing stoic community essentially
through the stock fellowship your branch
is in it awesome
what are the people who are are coming
to talk about and study stoicism in
Norway particularly interested well
we're actually shrinking as one was five
and so over adopted two or three active
members and well the problem was some
people want different things you know so
someone were very studying the
philosophy or academic weights so so
much as much make them more virtuous and
more happier yeah that's kinda stuff
some other people are critical that
wants to really dig into a few things
like is there such a thing as human
nature yeah
yeah that's a tough set of things to
juggle yeah and also some of their ideas
in the zeitgeist um II relativism seems
to be weak yes
who are you to tell me how it was in my
life that's we have a bit of that with
people who come in to the Milwaukee
Stoics but then they don't stick around
yeah hello probably all tactic to us to
you yeah but also I mean it is
challenging to me that takes a lot to a
certain I'm not really an expert on the
matter yet so yeah well and then there's
so many challenges that aren't so much
content but our just managing scheduling
and getting people you know inevitably I
don't know if it's the way same way for
you but anytime we pick a meeting there
is somebody who's like well that's not a
good time for me yeah
a note
that's probably just said today that
they become yeah I think that's the way
to go
perhaps Norwegians can play it less
Americans do mostly yeah so what do you
think you're here at stoic on what are
you most looking forward to
I know you've already had some of that
getting to meet some of the people yeah
no it's great to be here all of a sudden
you won't pop so much yeah Chris of the
jail oh yeah all the people you all may
have seen on the Internet to read the
books something like that
that's definitely fun yeah also a
populist lowenfeld chips me cheese with
well that's right you you edit
indifference quarterly yeah people to
edit you stay on top of you ride heard
as we say you familiar with that
expression
no so he has a cowboy term you know get
the cows moving riding herd means you're
crowding them a lot yeah
things like that yeah so that's nothing
it's great to meet a few of those people
I think I so it'll change something
oh yeah no it's a good sound number some
of the founders of the historic
fellowship yeah yeah yeah they I think
they're I think at least one of them is
going to be here
I think what's down Dan is very active
with your lando Stoics so that's that's
quite good now they seem to be a very
active chapter compared to some of the
others and I get to make you that's
right yeah yeah so we're familiar with
each other but it's so different
yeah electronic medium where you can
only see you know the bottom of the
person yeah that's if it's not glitching
yeah yeah that's not a problem
eh it's like yeah they're using that
this is a bit of a topic but they're
using that as a means to connect up
stoney communities in other places so
the Australia s Toa contacts at each
year they've been having they've shown a
video of somebody that they haven't
Skype in but answering questions and it
seems like a really great tool to
I mean that's some pretty vast distance
we're used to talking across the
Atlantic but when you're talking across
the Pacific that's quite different back
to the text there are one line that I
really want to get right in okay so it's
it's that farm in a day a day of Mexico
I'm at Oregon the aristasura services
Nate of Tata is maximum so I have to die
if it's now I will die but if it's in a
little while I would have lunch
since our lunch has come yeah and then I
would eat at night
that's a future perfect
yeah yeah yeah that's that's interesting
quite the way informal group I have to
admit that I'm sort of lazy and spoiled
with having bulbs so I'll read it in the
English most of the time unless I'm
deliberately pushing myself into the
Greek but as soon as the English starts
to seem a little strange that I go to
the Greek and say well can what's
actually being sent here but I never I
never read either one like all the way
through do you have any good tips for
learning which the way I learned it was
completely idiosyncratic I you know I
took some ancient Greek classes when I
was in graduate school but I'd already
learned German and Latin by that time so
I had a strong basis man it was very
interested in comparative indo-european
linguistics so when I was learning Greek
I didn't do it the way
to learn the paradigms and do a lot of
unit drills and practices I was very
interested in it as a linguistic system
and I was interested in you know
synchronic their distance are you
looking at its one big system at one
point in time which is a bit artificial
with the classical Greek because you
know like epictetus is Greek is is
changed considerably it's quite a from
the Greek of Plato or even Aristotle's
can in between but then there's the D
economic thing we're looking at how did
how did things change over time and
because I was so interested in that that
gave me a leg up that most other
students didn't so I I didn't have to
actually learn paradigms because I would
learn and study the ship is such a place
you know it's really cool outing and
dramatic language as the polishes that
took place in Greek ways things were
assimilated and so then when I took the
tests I could I could pass on that basis
so it was sort of a way to sort of like
reverse engineering the things and
that's not the way people should learn
languages I think so I mean the only
other thing I can say is you're doing
and you just have to keep working at it
day after day after day you acquire more
and more vocabulary and you know how it
is each author has their own peculiar
language that they use so you have to
learn their particular glossary it's now
like you know we're speaking English now
and we're using a pretty standard
language if I interview some sort of
strange terms which I could do because
you know
regionalisms coming from Wisconsin I
guess you asked me about the water
fountain I say the bubbler is over there
what the hell's a bubbler right that
would be one thing but with with
play-doh or epictetus anything's ancient
authors its word after word after word
so sometimes some of the words only
occur in that author because we've lost
so many texts that's actually a good
question that's a very different
question so we only have maybe three to
seven percent of stoic texts that at one
time did exist what would you want if
you could have a stoic text that we know
existed which one would you want to have
seamless Republic since the choice okay
yeah maybe some text on determinism and
ethics then we get a little native
little glimpse into that through
cicero's on faint nation we don't have
any of the original texts stop
an alligator with the dog chained to the
that you yeah you can either run along
with the chariot yeah or you get dragged
by it
I think Seneca mentions it well and who
else this is Cyril mention it I think he
there's no bleak reference to it maybe
tussle and expectations yeah it's
interesting his wand esteem references
something like that as well when he's
talking about Cicero and the Stoics in
the City of God okay you know the
Christians took sole their early
Christians they had access to these
types yeah and some of them were
actually very receptive to the standards
Clement of Alexandria for example really
like them and I think the thing Regan
was used instead of monasteries to from
time to time them although they yeah
they changed the language so the
philosopher becomes the monk yeah I mean
as Socrates becomes Jesus yeah yeah yeah
that's kind of funny to think about
about that well you know they can't
Seneca and they had Cicero they didn't
have Marcus Aurelius after that that was
lost I think in the fourth or fifth
century Renaissance
thinking west at least yeah yeah in the
West the new region edition of markets
is actually it starts with a quote I
mentioned they wouldn't have ever lost
her alias right whereas the West there
are so many things because the Dark Ages
of the box we're the only ones to
preserve the most of his texts I mean
you know we think about the Renaissance
and they rediscovered on this text most
of them were rediscovered in monastery
libraries the monks had just lost track
of what they had as hold the ball lost
interests yeah I heard a few people
traveling a little to try to find some
sort of magnitude in a monastery far
away of something yeah you know and
there were monasteries built on
monasteries Hildegard of Bingen
who is you know in western Germany one
of the monasteries that she found it was
on the ruins of an old carriage inian
monastery so you could you could imagine
that that could have been case
where all the books are pretty pretty
prized
but there could have been cases where
monasteries actually reincorporated each
other's holdings to keep their records
so is there anything else that you'd
like to bring up in terms of the
translation and your stoicism I always
let my interlocutors have the last word
yeah I don't think that comes to mind I
think we've been through a lot okay well
thanks very much for coming on and hope
that that by viewers enjoy hearing about
all the news of efforts at translation
and it really is a major task you're
taking out yeah take me several years
yeah yeah there's no reason to party
good choice yes yes yes there will will
certainly put posts about it because
well you know I'll do another interview
with you when it becomes available
all right that would be a great thing to
do
you